moi je suis Marie-Andrée et en fait je
suis
l'image même de la ferme du Bel-Air
c'est le nom de ma structure en fait on
est au bois de Saint-Paul et on fait de
l'élevage élevage de volaille et suite à
ça je transforme les viandes
issues de mon élevage j'ai commencé par
des produits carnés parce que la demande
s'en faisait sentir qu'il dit élevage de
canards dit forcément foie gras
rillettes et tout ça il y a une demande
avec les foie gras avec les fruits d'ici
des ananas des mangues
c'est normal on a tropicalisé on a on a
personnalisé un peu le foie gras il y a
quand même une ouverture aussi bien dans
l'esprit que dans le palais
je suis au marché de producteurs donc
tous mes collègues qui font des fruits
et ses légumes c'est eux qui m'ont donné
en fait l'idée de transformer aussi des
légumes et des fruits et entre autres
maintenant là depuis à peu près un an et
demi mon cheval de bataille c'est les
légumes séchés et comme ça un énorme
succès justement parce que c'est un
produit ça reste un produit un petit
produit de luxe quand même c'est un
produit fin il faut innover tout le
temps pour que les gens mais quand ils
viennent quelque part ils sont contents
d'avoir quelque chose de nouveau mon but
à moi c'est de faire petit rester petit
et atteindre directement le consommateur
les gens me parlent ils me disent ce
qu'ils en pensent et je les retrouve en
fait d'une année sur l'autre d'une
exposition à l'autre sans le fait même
je crois que le Sénat et que les petits
salons qu'il y a parce qu'il y a aussi
les bien-être et compagnie tout ça je
pense que sans ça l'artisan est un peu
perdu
je fais du tressage de papier et ça fait
environ un an que j'ai commencé l'idée
m'est venue j'ai vu un reportage et ça
m'a donné envie de l'essayer et depuis
que j'ai commencé je me suis jamais
mérité mais pour tresser le papier il
faut faire d'abord préparer les bandes
de papier les enrouler en faire des
tubes et c'est ensuite qu'on commence à
le tresser donc il faut quand même
préparer beaucoup à l'avance pour
commencer le tressage les journaux les
pubs les magazines tout ce qu'on peut
avoir comme papier vous voyez il
m'arrive de peindre de pain de papier
parce que on est aussi coloré donc tout
dépend de ce qu'on veut donner comme
effet de l'endroit où on va mettre
l'objet
mettre de la couleur ou pas selon le
goût à la fin dès que j'ai fini le
tressage j'ai passé vernis pour protéger
d'humidité de la poussière donc ce qui
fait que s'il y a de l'eau qui tombe
dessus ça va pas l'abîmer quand je
commence à tresser je sais jamais ce que
je vais faire comme modèle et ça vient
au fur et à mesure on peut faire
beaucoup de choses des paniers qu'on
peut mettre dans la cuisine des caches
pots on peut faire des paniers à linge
des lampes des messages c'est très
maniable au niveau des formes on peut
vraiment faire ce qu'on veut et après
bon au niveau du recyclage on peut faire
on peut faire avec d'autres matières en
fait tout ce que tout ce que les gens
jettent en général que ce soit bouteille
papier même les vieux ventilos on va
tout ce qui peut être réutiliser je les
récupère avec les voisins les amis ils
me ramène tout je repeins je pense et
tout et je fabrique d'autres objets
mon activité s'est beaucoup de peinture
sur tous les supports mais en
particulier pour les décorations de la
table dans le verre les nappes les
chemins de table tout ce qui est un
petit peu l'art de la table aussi étant
donné que j'étais dans l'association de
création ça m'a motivé un peu plus comme
je faisais que des nappes et des
serviettes j'ai dit si j'associais des
vers pour la décoration et c'est comme
ça ça m'est venu de faire la peinture
sur verre masseuse d'inspiration mais ça
me vient de la nature
j'aime la nature j'aime les plantes
j'aime bien peindre des fleurs des
fruits c'est plus ma passion ça dépend
où on a trouvé la bouteille si elle est
vraiment vraiment sale bon d'abord le
redonner un peu à un état de propreté et
après il faut bien nettoyer l'extérieur
l'endroit où on va peindre avec de
l'alcool le sécher et ensuite
dessiner et puis appliquer sa peinture
une fois séché on le passe au four pour
qu'elle se fixe correctement pour qu'on
puisse le laver oui c'est mon premier
fait mal j'ai l'occasion de le faire
grâce à l'association de création j'aime
beaucoup le contact qu'on a chaque
exposition parce que déjà ça permet de
faire des connaissances et puis on reste
pas on reste jamais dans les mêmes coins
quand on est on expose donc les vers
chez les achète et après il y a beaucoup
de récupération souvent c'est les
bouteilles les carottes il y a des
belles choses dans ce qu'on jette
souvent qu'on peut récupérer il suffit
de redonner un petit peu de couleur